trailer it seemed like an action movie
to me but it was a teaser and again III
sort of around the corner I'm sure we'll
see more but the trailer showed a bunch
of things that you noticed that I didn't
because you saw a lot of behind the
scenes information you noticed a few
things in the trailer specifically the
way squads were working and how she
respond back on him can you talk about
that yeah and in a second I think we're
gonna try and grab the trailer I
literally like have a page and a half on
just that trailer okay but I know John
Luke has it up why don't we just kind of
slowly head your way through it because
because Aaron you know despite that
being clearly not straight gameplay with
no scripted and there was HUD on it but
as to reiterate again there are there
are things that trailers representing
that you can do in the game yeah so when
we just run it so there's a horse head
okay can we just stop at times okay yeah
so this is a scroll a little bit further
so this is a horse head statue you see
like teddy bears and lute this is very
likely tank customization it's probably
part of their live service so they have
like timed events where you think the
tank is difficult trophies and ornaments
for tanks yeah Kalea gold ornament
that's a customized Eagle Eagle Claw I'm
gonna be the most ridiculous flamboyant
looking person hell yeah
stop here
so that explosion in the hallway was
showing the physics in the game so you
see some of this in battlefield one but
it blows and the chandeliers fly
everywhere that's part of their like
destruction system and you'll see it in
a second again with the tank where the
tank goes through the house and they
mentioned that you yourself the player
will get blown away like a few feet
right yeah so you'll you'll see a lot of
stuff that I loved from like bad company
where there's like dirt in your face and
you're getting rocked by explosions yeah
so their tanks been disabled they run in
the house we immediately see
customization here you have the your
female protagonist this is multi player
by the way she's got a hook hand you see
like face paint war paint
dope jacket dope jackets they
immediately go into close quarters
combat by the way she's British and
she's rocking a Thompson SMG he's got a
silencer a suppressor of some sort on
his yeah so go back you missed that part
right here on the Left bullets are
coming through the walls so this is a
new feature in the game whereas before
you could only shoot through doors in
battlefield 1 or remove the whole wall
with the tank right like bullet like
contextual bullet holes is pretty big so
it's even more like maybe like Rainbow
six siege
so that LMG is in particular can go
through walls which is really cool you
can just rate walls we think there's
people in there this guy is in a new
down but not out state so in the real
life system yeah yeah that so in
battlefield 2 everything is based around
your your squad so when you go down you
go into an over-the-shoulder of your
squad mates and you never get kicked
back to the orbital screen unless your
entire squad gets wiped out so um hold
on a second did we see what's on his
back right now
he's got a [ __ ] samurai yeah okay so
down Bernard out statement you have two
buttons that you can press one of them
is call for help and one of them is give
up okay
this gets even crazier because actually
now people in your squad can revive you
not just the medic Evan
everybody can revive you but so cool
they can't give you house only the medic
can give you health and only the medic
can revive people outside of your squad
that's cool okay so everything right now
keeps you in your school also it's funny
when the lady got shot at the banding
and went down that was what she was in
the down but not out stage she wasn't
actually dead okay also why don't you
mentioned that apparently you can drag
or did you say that all right I was yes
yeah so this is huge so I like to think
of you know the real live system
incorporated with this new mechanic is
that this is confirmed they're gonna do
this yeah they're going to allow players
to drag and pull a downed player like
too but like behind cover and then you
know administer a rival because if
you're not emetic it's gonna take you a
lot longer you're gonna want to get your
downed player out of the line of fire if
that makes sense you can drag down
players which is so cool like I always
want to be able to drag players behind
cover before reviving yeah
John Luke will have to go all the way
back to the house so we're just gonna
call out a lot of stuff in here we see a
little bit further back we see an
execution from behind and the player
comes up the stairs so that's returning
is the the like instant execution from
behind then we look over this dude looks
out the window and we see a tank rolling
on the house this trailers freak with
destruction so this is part of their no
fluid movement system horse knows go
back yeah yeah talk about this this is
really cool
okay so in battlefield one is super
awkward you run up to Windows and you
got a whack at them with your shovel and
hopefully get through no more so now you
run up two objects you press a button
and you do things like leap through
second-story windows enroll this is an
actual feature in the game this is the
rear perón so they develop the
developers love perón they like talked
about this for half the time so you can
now fall on the ground and crawl
backwards or like fall on the ground and
slide sideways and there's full 360
degree movement from the prone position
so you can do this you can crawl
backwards and shoot or like run and
slide and crawl backwards and shoot so
this this like running and jumping on a
window and rear sliding that's all in
multiplayer and we're like I don't know
if you could do this but P imagine like
doing a rear prone
down a stairway as you're firing
backwards like Trinity crashing through
that window and the pheasant is actually
right Cuba weaving chasing you there's
something right there through the
background the towing so we're not even
done with that scene back this is this
is just so Private Ryan by the way back
with burns at burns or so the tank
coming through the house they have a new
destruction system on houses so it's not
candid all that has physics when a tank
goes through a house all the debris will
go in the direction that the tank goes
but they also said there's crazy stuff
like if a tank shell hits a house it'll
blow it but if a tank shell goes through
a window and blows inside the house
that's a different type of explosion and
it'll blow stuff like out of the house
out of the back of the house so and
after this house is destroyed then we're
gonna get into the fortification system
where players can then rebuild that
house with sandbags
so here's light vehicles stop right here
so that is the tow yeah this is so sorry
go okay so as part of the fortification
system teams have headquarters and in
those headquarters there are tanks and
things that you can tow so like what is
this like an 88 flat gun sure so you can
go to the back of the base go hook up
like a flat gun to a tank and drive off
and your buddy can be in the flat gun
shooting while you're driving right so
that's so cool because you have people
building up these fortifications which
we'll see in a second and then if you
get if your team gets like held up on a
fortification you can go back to your
headquarters grab a buddy and a flak gun
and go like reduce it right so cool
which also means you're never gonna know
where the flak guns are on the map
because people can tell I mean if you
can imagine - if this is like a towing
feature whether it's at launch or down
the road you could probably tell other
things right never take off and land in
planes maybe if they're gonna introduce
that like oh hello movement aspect we
hope I mean like yeah I like or like a
glider like you know like it's like like
like d-day invasion where they had
gliders with like jeeps and stuff and
yeah and those things like that could be
something down the road like if that's a
if that's a prominent feature right like
this towing mechanic
that tank also had like a with log
strapless side which is more
customization yeah so yeah you brought
this up this is you know there's there's
an event happening maybe and this is you
know if you can measure the big the
middle of the map if this is a
LEvolution
type thing or the bridge blows like this
seems to be very pronounced action here
right like jeeps and vehicles flying off
of the bridges here so they didn't
specifically say a LEvolution but in
concept art we've seen this bridge hole
yeah so I think there's a good chance
that was a LEvolution event if you go
back just real quick to the plane
crashing and the dude getting thrown
messerschmitt bf-109 by the one so this
is yeah so this is likely physics in the
game again this is this is a
representative trailer like we haven't
actually played the game so I can't
confirm any of this hands-on but the do
getting tossed and then the airplane
lands and the pilot gets out if this is
in the game and I'm not confirming this
bar because they didn't talk about
planes but that'd be sick if you could
crash in the little crush land in this
game and laughs yeah baby dude that
that's that's a really strong point
because that is something that is I
would say has never been that before
like and that's also in Aeryn we talk
about this like to death which is like
in a lot of BALCO games I would say
arguably since for there have there has
been a separation of air game and ground
game where you feel a little disjointed
you're just doing some strafing runs and
then you're getting shot down eventually
by more or less another pilot than any
pilot here opposed to just like ejecting
like you could you can have this intense
moment of like crash landing right yeah
if you don't have a shoot or something
like that like that could be that could
be really fun like I don't know I hope
that's in the game so let's stop here
and here's that camouflaging mission
yeah let's go back to the gun on the
ground so there's a lot going on in this
shot here so first of all this is part
of the scarcity system so everything in
this game is tied into getting players
to play objectives which is something we
talked about being a problem earlier so
the fortifications get you attached to
actually defending points and then the
squad system has you and actually Rob
you mentioned this before you have to
spot or sorry you join a game in a squad
well then you have to choose to go solo
yeah so you get
you've run out of ammo on this game this
game has ammo scarcity you actually run
out of ammo between lives you don't get
your ammo back all your ammo back when
you spawn so this that's cool this gun
that got picked up there's only ten
bullets in it
so immediately a person no ten out of 50
sorry ten hundred fifty so like maybe
one drum right right so this person
immediately needs a support class person
around or they need to get to an
objective to pick up ammo this does look
like conquest assault by the way with
the tickets on top and they're you know
they're trying to take a couple of
points a B and C okay so they pick up a
gun it only has like one drama of ammo
in it stop here we can see the
fortification system in the game so this
is a capture control point those
sandbags are in the game so there's the
players are they're physically building
this fortification on a control point
and that's something that everyone can
do is build what's the list you can
build sandbags you can put up boards
trim these trenches or wire was it tank
teeth yeah so is that for like anti
mines and stuff like that is that the
idea between behind tank teeth yeah just
doctor so you don't get those actual for
fication it's not like something put on
tank guy so these are at set points on
the map they didn't did they're not like
completely dynamic they are at they've
had all the major control points on the
map we see a flat gun that probably got
all right sorry I know it's her can
independent toad up there yeah we see an
engineer with like a with a rocket but
so this is real this is in the game and
this is being built by players while
they're playing and that was something
they in that stream they touched on
which was one of I think one of the
gripes or problems with Bal killed one
was that again that's in Quinn Quinn in
San Quentin scar thank you God yeah we
mention this when you were playing
earlier yeah like like there are moments
where you know say the behemoth
comes in because the other team is just
getting stomped on comes in like halfway
through the the match and can just level
the entire town so when you're going to
try to cap a flag you don't have any
obstacles our cover around you you're
just prone and everyone could see you so
that's that's what they're kind of
offering us a solution right is like
putting up these fortifications I really
like that like instead of saying let's
decrease destruction they're like no
let's keep destruction as well as it was
if not increasing on it but let's give
people a chance to reverse it if they
want if they so choose and it does like
to support classes have more rebuilding
options or is everybody pretty much like
sandbag capable so what they said was
anybody can build okay um but you can
also specialized classes in this game
now so it's possible that as a support
class you may be able to build more than
and I'm speculate and I tanks that have
a sort of cooldown right yeah like that
the old school were builds faster I
don't know yeah that's very likely the
only the only specific specialization
they actually said as an example was an
assault class who could specializes
anti-tank which actually did happen it
was one thing that had me a bit
concerned that maybe like they're
talking about making squads in classes
rely on each other but then they said
something that kind of watered down us
all class a little bit cuz bad for one
had that they had the anti-tank gun
rocket gun hit ability right for assault
class yeah they did there wasn't really
an engineer class but it hardly had
enough rounds to actually stop a tank so
you needed a support guy next to you
trying ammo right um okay it was let's
dive back in yeah okay so this gun is
fully customized you can see it has a
leash camo it has a muzzle brake it
probably has like a custom stock I got a
bottle opener so this is part of again
they're like yeah probably does have a
bottle of it this is all part of their
fluid movement system so that assault
class player he just picked up and threw
a grenade back that wasn't his grenade
oh I missed that so now if you want to
go back real quick that was part part of
probably a specialization but that was a
toss back so it comes in that's an damn
cool and we can also see like the large
battle going on the background um a lot
of this part is showing the pro system
so this is all the moves you can do
while you're prone he's like crawling
spinning his gun is constantly up while
here yeah cool or wine that once I made
whatever is video game but this guy is
one handing and
mg42 crawling getting kills it's it's
awesome I mean this this trailer alone
seems like tonally so much different
like World War one they went so somber
and McCobb with it like especially that
I mean the intro of the game again we
haven't played this but the intro of the
game was you fighting that impossible
battle and everybody dies when you
switch between the characters right this
one seems like they're self-aware I mean
we saw samurai sword we saw this girl
what is that by the way that creates a
cricket bat what is with barbed wire I
mean I think you know I think people
were fans of the series right I think I
was hearing some people talk about like
oh they really wanted another bad
company hmm maybe this is kind of
tonally yeah holing submission pulling
some of that frankly just like fun right
into the game even then even then like
saying like being self-aware enough to
say he's like or what did she say she's
like I'm not dead or something what'd
she say we should get shot at the
beginning I forgot what she said she's
like someone says she's hit she's like
no I'm not or whatever and she's
response yeah yeah got shot in the
stomach and she's talking and she's got
a claw hand yep sorry to give credit
where it's due a lot of this came in and
battlefield hardline it was contextual
call outs crazy melee weapons a lot of
things that mean like particularly mean
that players know what's going on
without relying on voice chat and the
characters in the game can't actually
call out what's happening at any given
time there was I I mean I guess I didn't
really like consciously like consider it
but that in the background there that
was like dc-10 planes like Peartree
Paris I was jumping out yeah so that's a
thing so what they mentioned for their
grand operations mode was that there are
certain maps where you spawn in the in
the plane and you choose when to jump
out onto the map so it's not just a
spawn here it's actually paratroopers
okay like how you enter a battle royale
again interesting that we talked about
before like hey it can work you know
like at least at least it's not from
what it looks like it's not just here's
a battle royale mode right like here is
a way of looking at the trends and
corporations without a feel game that
seems neat in a way instead of stealing
the boat out or instead of borrowing the
mode outright it's like stealing what
makes those games appealing and what can
also work for battlefield like the
survival aspects being able to drag
people being able to revive anybody but
the medic being more important in that
respect and also helping other squads it
does seem like there's uh there's more
focus on not dying
which sounds obvious but like again and
battlefield one I felt like in
battlefield 4 and hardline I felt like
that sentiment was lost I felt like I
was more worried about kills this one
seems like it's more about surviving so
you can help your squad if what they've
said in this trailer and what you saw
yesterday or any indication yeah I liked
it the further on that like that kind of
revived system right like they see me a
really heavy hand in the idea that like
anyone can be revived mm-hmm by anyone
doesn't have to be just a medic and I
could just do it very fast but then heal
and heal yeah and there was another I
think they mentioned that no longer if
like from alpha 1 which was for a static
sample I'm pretty neat but you're no
longer getting warped back out to that
bird's-eye view right like when you you
mentioned earlier when you die you are
behind your squad mates and it's very
much about keeping that squad alive and
being with your team again you're
spawning in and you're not solo we have
to like opt out manually you're
automatically in a squad that's neat
like I want to see that I mean the
survival aspect also goes back to the
ammo scarcity we saw just before the
woman saved you at the end that you had
a 19 rounds left the player in the
trailer had 19 rounds left before she
knocked in the face of the cricket bat
and then again that encourages you to
rebuild those fortifications that
encourages you to actually fight around
those objectives and you know presumably
you said that you heard that yesterday
that you might have already mention this
forgive me we're talking about a lot but
the tanks have to return to objectives
to restock that was something that we
hope to be the gotcha
okay sorry so they only talked about
that that's true for soldiers so
soldiers will run out of ammo more
quickly and they must be around either
like squad mates orbs or good objectives
so everything is designed to not let you
just go roaming and like you screw off
and not pay attention to us I hope the
same rings true for vehicles because
then that would say light that would
take away
I had with battlefield one was vehicles
sometimes felt overpowered I mean I
their vehicles it makes sense if you had
an anti-tank on it was an easy way to
take them out but I feel like if you had
if they did run out of ammo they to
return to objectives imagine how like
treacherous and scary that would be to
be really far from your nearest if
you're active run out of your last like
your last shell you're like [ __ ] we have
to get back here for this final push
every has to wait for these vehicles to
get back meanwhile there's people like
that know that you're going back to
restock so they're just trying to take
out vehicles while they're defenseless
that would be really cool again that's
just like pure speculation like wishful
thinking but I think it would be pretty
awesome like yeah I increase the
reliance on you know like worrying about
your ammo and the objectives which
you're all there already like you know
reinforce it yeah and to reiterate on
the idea of like preserving objectives
is what you just kind of made me realize
is if this does pan out the way I'm
thinking about it is preserving the
frontlines in a way right like you're
keeping people coming back to objectives
because I think sometimes like even like
the battlefield 1 match we're playing it
just becomes kind of like a mix where
it's it's almost like a circle right
it's like objectives going down oh great
now they took AI got go back to a well
now a loss of D like like maybe that's
gonna keep people coming back to these
objectives so they're not just so barren
all the time because you spawn than any
leave right you're you're now you're
falling back so actually if you go to
the end of this match in the trailer you
can see that they're losing a point
behind them oh really well I mean that's
just that's just whoa hey get start to
get taken Oh F they start to lose D
again in the middle of this yeah there's
more reason to hold on to now outside of
points it seems like it seems like
that's their intent one of the biggest I
love that yeah
one of the biggest criticisms of people
I know who play they play a lot of
conquest so that people just take the
points and then ditch yeah and so this
gives you a reason an investment in the
points which is really important it
looks like turtling like an RTS when
you're actually I got I can see myself
being a support player who takes this
point is like you guys go I'm just gonna
hold this for the rest of the match and
have fun doing that I'll build up
anti-tank defenses I'll get an anti-tank
weapon all you know I've got my cricket
bat I'm fine my samurai sword so what
just happened they're looking on screen
if we can show the
execution but it's kind of funny
actually from the player's perspective
what's happening here is the player goes
down and if you go back a little bit
further she's dead and she squads bonds
so this this poor chap Oh ice now you're
I go you say yeah so she pops up his
butt right there plus 20 and this dude's
in the middle of the like an amazing
execution you might be that guy and he
got squad spawn kill so she squats
bother than melee to him while he was
nailing okay somebody else so they did
show actually to be fair like this might
be the trailer they showed danger spawn
lockout so maybe you couldn't do that in
the actual game maybe they just did that
okay like I don't know it just
immediately reminds me of like Halo
Legends or Halo co-op when you had to
respawn at someone when they were safe I
know there are other games have done
that since but your honor fire you can't
spot I do yet she was dead and she
squats bones listen anything specific
with a trailer I do want to talk about
I'm seeing these characters in the
customization the co-op mode they
mentioned co-op specific combined arms
this seems like a separate mode it's not
war stories it's not co-op campaign per
se it's not multiplayer pvp it's a PvE
co-op mode and you said this might be
their solution to having like a horde
because it is for players and its
randomly generated and also they said
the objectives are gonna be different
from time to time it also sound almost
sounds like you're dropping into you
know chalice dungeons in blood-borne
what do you want to say underground and
division it's like these randomly
generated objectives that you can drop
into a presumably to get aesthetic loot
and just to play with friends against
you know AI enemies it seems very
similar to perhaps onslaught mode from
Bad Company 2 earlier which was a pv
vironment it's interesting you're
actually one of the lead guys david
goldfarb from alpha 31 often made payday
2 which also had these like co-op PvE
like random randomly generated things
but the most important important part of
that is that it is randomly generated
I loved the co-op in battlefield 3
actually thought it was a good campaign
and it'd be really cool it's really cool
that to jump in with your buddies and
not have the same experience every time
now we didn't we didn't see it so like I
don't know maybe it's like a map where
like
objectives just move around yeah or
maybe it's a full-on they mentioned and
store something about stories so it
could be really cool like if it's
randomly generated stories that'd be
amazing okay if it's just randomly
generated I don't know like crates your
variety of objectives like this is a
weird deep not deep cuff but a few years
ago do you remember Helldivers number
next time you dropped in there was
different like take and hold this weapon
placement go clear out the enemies here
go if they could do if there's a variety
of objectives like so there's not like
maybe if they're rotating through six
it'll get old fast but if you drop into
we don't know if we're gonna go to
Russia Norway France we don't know if
we're gonna go to Italy North Africa we
don't know if we're gonna have to take
out this artillery weapon be really cool
that'd be fun with with an evac in the
end yeah yeah he said actually you might
have a point where you have to evacuate
just choose to bail out right like I you
I'm not an ammo right like there really
it seems like picking I mean I want to
say battle royale but just in general
like the survival trend right like
running out of ammo supplies like being
spread so thin like we got to evac now
no let's do this one last like that if
it's like a breathing world almost in a
way right like I don't know this is just
me spitballing but like knowing when to
call it quits right like we need to get
out of here
well it sounds like an ex comm campaign
like different objectives you're
actually trying to accomplish and you
can evac if you think you're screwed you
can just get out alright but that sounds
cool
I really do like the idea of that there
they said more stories of their
equivalent or no was that what was
called now feel one more stories uh yeah
I mean we'll do that again that was the
campaign yeah right so sorry combined
arms co-op but they are going back to a
campaign like short story form with more
stories
I don't know pers like it'd be cool to
see them they're talking about going
into uncharted territory the character
they show close up was a Norwegian woman
I'm you know so it'll talk about
Norwegian resistance against Nazis maybe
there would be like the British command
doesn't come in and do the the raids on
the coastline
I like that idea I like the idea of it
that's what they try to do with
battlefield 1 explore
you know seldom explored areas although
battlefield ones not usually in
videogames but I'd like to see them go
like just show characters from places
that we might not usually like maybe the
eastern early Eastern Front rather than
when Russia's invading Germany I'd like
to see I'd like to see more in Russia
that'd be really cool cuz Call of Duty
did a lot of that I mean they did that
with battlefield 1 but again that was
World War 1 I'm curious to see what they
do with war stories I like those I like
the little II want in like the Italian
one as much in the first one so I might
get my facts wrong in this and air and
you will have to help me out but the
idea with I don't know how much we
touched on it but the idea is that
throughout you know the DLC that's free
that will be coming along are like
different like factions or countries
that are being entered right and with
them come planes and iconic weapons and
stuff like that like that is that is the
case like like well like Americans be
brought in like a little bit later on is
or is that all gonna be a launch do they
have they touched on that they haven't
said what factions are gonna be there we
know and here we saw we had minimum stop
British yeah I think what they talk what
they touched on a bit more with that
seasonal content was like time to dance
it sounds like they're following like
the overwatch Rainbow six siege model
I'm gonna go out on a limb and assume
that like a lot of the cool
customization you get will probably come
from those timed events yeah anniversary
events like holiday stuff
one thing they did this was all
everything we saw today was European
theater concept art included yeah it
wasn't any Pacific no Pacific exactly
was that was that way I wonder if
they're they're talking about like
trying to paint the whole war right
everybody on board it would be weird not
to show a whole you know the part of the
war that lasted longest I don't know I'm
curiously gonna do that he talked a lot
about Norway so the one specific example
for the story was a story translated
into English was Northern Lights mmm-hmm
northerly was about a resistance
fighters and then she they showed us
like a little teaser where she drops
into the water she's wearing a pilot
outfit and they basically said that her
story is about family it's not about the
larger war mm-hmm so they said they
wanted to focus on smaller stories they
said they went digging through archives
look for little cool little tails that
might tie any key moments in the war
yeah but aren't necessarily nobody's
like storming the beaches or you know
like Battle of the Bulge I think they
said they want to focus on small
personal stories right and then like we
did talk about telling we talked about
vehicles I try to think of what we
didn't cover the last if you want to
show the last thing on that trailer so
there's actually more there the v1
rocket scene if we can pull that is a v2
v2 I think it's a v2 so the like they
love this prone um it's funny actually
so there's a lot of animations they
showed us they have a test map or that a
glider so that's a that's a view in
rocket Wow
so there's a lot to be right it's b1 yet
okay so this is actually a thing in the
game this is part of the it's called
squad leader radio so it is the
replacement for commander mode well I
don't worsen your placement because I
didn't talk about commander mode but
it's the equivalent of commander mode so
going back to the idea of sticking in
your squad your squad has a squad leader
and that squad leader accumulates points
as their squad plays the objectives and
follows orders and basically plays well
the squad leader then can spend those
points in the middle of a match to do
things like call in the v1 rocket Oh
like Pat way more like MP attacks and
stuff yeah okay cool some of the things
that they were talking about sounded a
lot like behemoths so I think the squad
leaders can now this is probably a
counter to fortifications the squad
leaders can now call in powerful attacks
as long as people are playing the squads
playing in their squad and playing
objectives to counter things like giant
they can call the giant tanks and like
Oh kinda stuff oh wow ammo resupplies
Danny Berlin the creative director
during that stream said the term secret
weapons and numerous times you could
turn the tide of war I wonder if that's
in relation to that but I immediately
thought behemoths when he said that but
it makes more sense that v1 rocket I
don't know maybe like like you said
calling a squad of tigers if you're on
the German side or I
no idea what of what else would be
involved advance that gives you more
incentive to play the objective you're
accumulating points through that as well
because yeah and battlefield one if
you're a commander you were just pretty
much issuing commands right saying let's
go take this objective and if they took
that objective then you get points thank
you my you could rake up experience yeah
that was about it
in three you could kill people with
resupply crates which was kind of
satisfying Oh calling it in yeah and but
that's all on the ground now so now it's
the squad leaders who have those
powerful attack okay cool
I don't know there any huge points we
didn't touch on do you want to talk
about there's a lot last thing I could
think of is explaining what battlefield
one's mode operations is now called
grant operations the battlefield 5 yeah
which is like you know a series of
matches and modes that transition over a
period of I think days is what they're
calling it wants be gone that yeah so
one things they talked about was great
operations that went for about five days
four to five days and not real-time
sorry well okay I didn't know if you
meant like it's gonna start on October
19th and you could play at any point
it's it it's like five rounds in game
right okay cool
it's different from like a mixed mode
server in that the progress from one
carries it to the next so they actually
talked about it a bit in the stream but
you know you might have fewer tickets if
you don't do so well in round two or you
might have less ammo
they say that you might actually like if
you'd really stuck you could actually
get to the last day and have like one
mag left in your gun like Stalingrad
yeah so do yeah that example was like if
on day four you have one mag left in
your pistol day five starts with one mag
left in your pistol yeah who's wasting
all of your ammo on like suppressing
someone that's not even there they'll
[ __ ] I have two rounds left yeah I mean
I think both of you guys have nailed it
and in that they you know they they they
have not talked about a battle royale
which makes me think it's probably not
gonna be in this game but they have
channeled the spirit of battle rail in a
way with a lot of their mechanics that
might appeal to to battle royale fans
yeah like the idea I think of Battle
Royale is like I kill an enemy what is
have right and and and the law that is
loot management like yeah I got a clip
left
this guy's got a different gun in ain't
what I have but my odds are better with
this so now I'm a sniping like I'm
changing my exact play style based on
you know the environmental stuff as well
like going to an off school I'm sorry
objective like my continuing my loadout
or am I gonna like ditch it and do
something else
yeah it has pretty neat and they'll be
grand operations and like you said the
progress between rounds or days in the
game whether it be four or five is
continuous and then each presumably like
each day would have a different
objective for the attacking team
different things to take different
things to control yeah like I think what
we heard whether or not you heard
something similar was that maybe like
day three would be an airborne drop yeah
as a counter to what events proceeded in
day that's a three day - right like it's
it seems to be more locked in where it's
not like I feel like with operations
prior where it's you know yes something
happened in the previous map or mode but
the but the slate is kind of wiped clean
it seems like it's the they're still now
a losing side like you're taking
consequences and ramifications of what
happened in the day before like that
seems neat where you can look at at the
span of five days and be like there's a
there's more of an interlocking or like
a story involved we're like we were down
that we came back like I'm even thinking
of Carentan like day one would be allies
taking the town day two would be
defending against the German
counter-attack day 3 would be finally
pushing the battalion out of the area or
something w
totally know or like the idea that like
you made a grand
I said grand a really last-ditch effort
to take a town successful you do yeah
but what happens in the next and like in
the next day well your shore and
supplies are like you're you know you
ran out of ammo now you have to like
defend and hold up and like pray that
you know the next team isn't gonna like
stop your heart I don't know and I'm
excited for the mode because that's what
my one thing before the stream started I
was saying I want
battlefield to go back to the big
picture and if you're thinking two days
in advance then that's big picture I
like that idea yeah you're thinking
supplies over a whole campaign not just
this firefight I mean you might get to
the end of a round that you're about to
lose in and conserve your ammo over the
next round where I you it'd be
interesting to see people strategically
play switch to your cricket bat yeah
yeah your ninja sword
that you guys saw anything else we want
to touch on yeah um one thing they
talked about was their go back to their
fluid movement system so as a player oh
yeah you're always you're always in
first person and your shooting is not
impacted but what you see from people
around you are people doing things like
slipping and sliding on the mud you'll
see people run up and like throw a
shoulder into a wall when people get
into water they'll like start
high-stepping so there's a lot of stuff
that's invisible to you but will like
help your immersion because you'll see
your buddies doing it that's gotta be
tough to work with like hitboxes like if
you got if you're running into effect
someone sees you run into a wall but
really on your screen you didn't I
wonder how they're gonna account for
that from the other person like shooting
at you I'm curious yeah I mean I think
it depends on try to look good yeah um I
think there's a bigger danger this is
always been the battlefield it's the
perception of what you think happened
versus what happened
yeah like battlefields had some latency
issues where you die and you're like I
was clearly behind that wall yeah before
I died for like a peekers advantage and
siege comes from - yeah um let me flip
through some notes really quick just to
make sure I haven't because like there's
so much to talk about
yeah you're only on our phone call
yesterday yeah it was actually like a
three hours so theythey are for half an
hour thing here it's a like three hours
oh they talked a lot about so they
talked about here they talked a lot
about in 1942 being there their big
influence all I'm just a start I'm just
gonna hit some random points here they
talked about dynamic weather being in
the game still they talked about amping
up disruption see we're talking about
customization um
gun recoil which we talked about earlier
where where where you shoot is where the
bullets go
robbed that was the v1j v2 rockets it
was a JB - that's where you're right you
were right I was not I looked at the v2
bait it just looks like a giant like
Looney Tunes a sprocket it's nothing
like I mean it is really cool how people
get thrown in like bad company like you
get all that dirt and the concussions
that even bomb you know like bath weed
one had that really cool aesthetic right
up to like mud and grid and stuff gangly
your gun one moment some dude like blew
up in his face and there's blood all
over his mg you know that's cool so the
commander ability is where the rocket
supply drops smokescreen barrage heavy
weapon battle pick up and these sounded
like the behemoths the Churchill
crocodile which is the British tank and
the squirming ger stern tiger cool steel
tiger steering and that's the German one
um assuming there would be more that's
the one thing you heard about sure okay
so that's just more specifics um I am
really curious about what we did see a
number of weapons in the game but I'm
curious how far into prototypes they
will go yeah like that is one thing I
care because they were yet by the end of
World War two I wonder if they're gonna
go that far or if that's part of their
like season of cons I think that's down
the road I mean look at you look at any
game even battlefield 1942 the
expansions were road to Rome and then
secret weapons of world war ii which we
had freaking helicopters which i that
was not there but yes the war had the
you know like the the German
Messerschmitt 262 and British like new
year I think there were jets towards the
end so yeah it would make sense for that
to me like a later update or some like
that sac fly jets yeah other small
mechanics so there's no more auto
spotting they said and I think
battlefield ones trying to crack down on
spotting they actually limited the range
in recent DLC so you can't just like
look at a hillside in spam spot okay and
see where everybody is so there's no
auto spotting that's limited and jumping
oh right dolphin diving so like you
mentioned you might be able to run
like slide down a stairway backwards
while you're shooting get up Trini yeah
so they said you can jump from the apex
and down so like if you've leap you
can't shoot in the first part of your
jump but you can just do the second part
so maybe dolphin diving will make a
comeback I hope not
Oh for people who don't know what
dolphin diving is that's that's that's
jumping and I going prone you could do
that gotcha oh yeah you can do that in
modern warfare - was that like big go
okay yeah jumping out windows shooting
that make sense I just didn't know that
term I was counting drop shopping but
then getting back drop shotting but
getting back up yes talking about the
matrix yeah just like running and doing
these like dives he's beginning to
believe sweetie barrels
anyway the side job keep going can you
nevermind this whole things aside yeah
yeah really yeah they said they're
trying to get away from revive trains
where like you just kill somebody you
kill the whole squad except for the
medic and then they just all revive each
other but then like a sentence later
they're like oh anybody came above
anybody so I don't really know how that
fits together I love that but maybe it's
like when squad did wiped everybody gets
kicked orbit and that's what they're
talking about yeah but they're trying to
avoid that frustrating moment where you
have a great plan to kill everybody
except for one person you die and then
they just revive everybody there's
there's got to be just like a longer
respawn yeah yeah something like that
where you again you're you're the
incentive to revive someone is very
heavy-handed opposed to like you're like
40 feet away from me I could get back in
quicker by respawning right like I think
that's something they're trying to avoid
yeah
just dial back you mentioned like the
dolphin dive but there's also no auto
vaulting right or auto mat mantling so
you have to like I would imagine like
almost double jump or time it correctly
to like jump over a fence or climb up on
trip and faceplant if you don't write
they I mean they didn't I'm not sure
exactly what they were getting out there
I think the issue is that maybe people
getting stuck on things Oh
or like I don't know what they were
saying was it was there trying to make
more fluid movement so you don't have
those awkward moments where you're like
banging on a window trying to spread
that then okay um but no you're correct
there's no auto vaulting so you have to
press a button for it to happen got it
so maybe they were worried about you the
fluid movement system where you like
accidentally hit a window and go through
it the drunk effect whoops
wednesday's three-story building hang on
guys I need to do over yeah yeah like in
general that that movement system seems
really cool okay um dang I think that's
it I think it's time so that's a
combination of what we saw in a trailer
with a southern stream and a ton of what
you heard yesterday if you join us today
thank you so much if you're on GameSpot
or youtuber twitch we will have more on
the game from what we know so far Dave
juoh in the UK office was at that event
that we just watched on the stream so
we'll have more coming out I'm sure
you'll have much more to talk about
Aaron I don't know maybe we'll do a few
like videos or something when the time
comes and then of course III is what
three weeks away or something if that
and we'll all be down there in the Los
Angeles or and up here and safe just go
covering all the press conferences and
hopefully seeing more battlefield 5
absolutely I mean we definitely will but
thank you so much for joining today
Robin Aaron thanks for joining on you so
much thank you guys for watching me I'm
pretty I'm pretty excited for it October
19th
is that correct and then so in the
deluxe edition you can play October 16th
and then October 11th if you have EA
access that's the play first trial for
Battlefield 5 on Xbox one PC and ps4 all
three platforms on October 11th great
thank you so much for joining and stick
around games ba for more from
battlefield 5 we'll see you then
you